Aladin rolled with a very different crew  he had a boo the monkey and of course  Will Smith is the genie and in this  exclusive behind-the-scenes footage it  seems there was a real method to wills  Genie madness right I just went all in  on the genie life he took the genie  stuff pretty seriously always pretending  he was in a lamp when I commit I commit  will did magic tricks on Seth he will  been granted wishes for his co-stars  wish it was lunch already  your wish is my command it's time now  hey put them up is down that's breakfast  muffin put them down but the real magic  of will is a genuine good guy check out  how he made dreams come true for these  four year old twins I think it is now  all delicious where's my magic when I'm  in public I can't use my magic since  people can't know I'm a genie wait a  minute Puccini used his magic to turn  into ice yo man  [Music]